on company updates please be honest
there for you and not for us and if you
make them clearly crazy like you know
we're never ever launching we're
launching in four million years
we'll get the hint so don't do that
there have been a lot of questions about
the graduation requirement which was
that you had to submit nine out of ten
weekly updates it this course was
originally a ten week course and things
changed around a little bit and it's
actually more of a nine-week course now
and so and it was a little bit difficult
for some groups to get going because of
our little snafu in the beginning of the
course so so here's the deal
eight out of nine updates is just fine
but we're also going to extend the class
oh actually really two weeks beyond the
last lecture so that there will be
plenty of time to do ten updates if you
so choose and you choose to do nine out
of ten but eight out of nine will be the
absolute requirement for consideration
for the four that the $10,000 grant
so we're will be flexible but make them
good updates make them real updates
another reminder those weekly updates
are due 11:59 p.m. every Sunday
Pacific Standard Time there's been some
confusing confusion about that as we've
written it a number of times but please
recall when that is a questions again
about anything about about your
moderators about your groups about your
updates please send to start-up school
at Y Combinator comm and my very last
note is a reminder to launch if you
haven't already the only way to find out
if you've made something that people
really
is to have people really use it so get
your products out there if you haven't
now I'm going to introduce our first
speaker who is uh my esteemed partner at
Y Combinator Gustov astronomer who in
2012 was part of the group that built
the growth team at Airbnb and if you
know anything about Airbnb you know from
2-12 2012 for the next five years they
grew an enormous amount this is
something that Gustav knows better or at
least as good as anyone in the entire
world so I'm thrilled to have him talk
today about growth thank you very much
before I begin thank you so much to
Steven Jeff adora bill for putting all
this together so we can be her and do
this today I'm going to talk about
growth my background before joining YC
last summer was being one of the first
person on the growth team at Airbnb and
then growing that team from I think we
were three people in the beginning this
is how many people were in 2015 we then
grew two hundred and hundred and twenty
people or something like that
almost everything I'm talking talking
about today here I owe this group that's
sort of what I learned all this stuff
some of the best ways to learn to work
on user growth is to actually work on a
growth team and I was fortunate to do
that for for almost five years ago
Airbnb
so before I start one of the questions
that might be obvious the answer might
be obvious for some people but not for
everyone is sort of like why should we
do this
why is growth important and I I'm
surprised how often I actually get this
questioned but it might be worth
thinking about it for a second so when
you make a product some people think
that if you just put that product into
the market people will come and people
will start using the product in my
experience that's not really how to work
world
if you start a startup or a company
that's aim to be a start-up growth is
important because that's actually what a
start-up is if you make something that
has the potential to be really big then
making that really big is sort of what
starts all about there's actually post
that Paul Graham wrote that it's called
startup equals growth where he talks
about specifically why growth is so
important for startups and why it's not
important why not every company's to
startup and why growth isn't important
for every company but for startups it's
it's really really important and I'll
talk in the second sort of like what it
means to be intentional by growth but
but the first question is you kind of
have to answer yes to is sort of like I
have a startup I want to grow now how do
we go about doing that so who's this
talk for in my experience those kind of
things you work on one and work on user
growth started with consumer companies
those were the companies that started
embracing a lot of the tactics and
strategies and technologies that growth
teams were doing now I would argue that
almost every company that sells anything
online or get users online should be or
could be using a lot of the skills and
knowledge that I'm gonna talk about
today so you don't need to be just a
consumer company you don't need to be
just a social network to apply these
things these are applicable to a wide
range of companies if you're a b2b
company and are excellent at growth you
have a massive advantage to other
companies in your space because they are
probably not going to spend as much time
doing growth as you are now
there's one type of companies who this
is relevant for but too early and that
actually might apply to most of you
right now
and this is what this talk is dangerous
because working on growth the wrong time
in your company's history can be
detrimental
for you it's sort of like when you are
kind of off to the races a little bit
too ahead of time so the most important
thing which is was a lot of lectures
here start school is about is how you
make something people want and how you
actually find product market fit if you
apply a lot of the things I'm going to
talk about here to a company that hasn't
built something people want or haven't
actually found product market fit really
bad things happen you will very often
then this is a very common graph grow
like crazy in the beginning but then
when you realize that sort of like that
fuel they had isn't fueling anything
it's just fueled kind of evaporates you
come straight down so that's why it's
dangerous and now I'll I can go into
more details about that in a second of
applying some of these things before you
actually have product market fit so the
first thing I'm talking about today is
going to be around measurement around
proc market fit because that's actually
the most essential part for for
continuing growth now do growth teams
have impact or are growth team sort of
like like how do you know that growth
seems actually matter how do you know
that that these things man I'm gonna
talk about that as well like my
experimentation but before I get there I
want to tell your story from Facebook
and this is not a story I came up with
myself I found it on one of the talks
from Facebook and I think it's so
essential for describing the level of
impact you can have if you are applying
these kind of skill sets to a company so
this is the timeline of Facebook from
2004 to 2015 is sort of their growth
story some of this is public some of
some of this wasn't the one thing
Facebook had they had an excellent data
science team from the early days they
were really good at measuring sort of
like forecasting how big face was going
to be so back in 2006 2007 when Facebook
had just started the girth team they had
a bunch of data scientists doing this
sort of forecasting how big will
Facebook eventually be and they looked
at all the type of metrics at
facebook.com/ and and they came to
conclusion that Facebook will be roughly
400 million
by 2015 that was their forecast by using
all the data they had now we know that
wasn't really true they actually started
growing really fast in 2008-2009 and
this actually as a result of something
that the growth team came up with and no
one here had an idea what make Facebook
growth so fast in 2000 2008 roughly
she's in 7g a opening to high school
students yes they did but that wasn't as
a big of a growth newsfeed was 2005
sorry recession recession did not know
10 friends and yeah that's good actually
it's sort of like the girls story all
across a Michigan could have been that
translations is the answer so this is
surprising for many for many of you
might maybe but there's actually core
part of many growth teams is that you
want to make your product available for
as many people in the world and Facebook
star is sort of hitting the limit on
people who spoke English and then assume
that people just because Facebook was in
English and so that the content were in
local language and Facebook were in
English it would continue to scale that
wasn't the case so they implement this
new platform that automatically
translated Facebook into hundreds of
languages and and the growth to be
accelerated
now the same thing started happen again
I think they call this lockdown boom
they were doing very important things in
2010 2011 something very big was
happening at Facebook how to make some
really large changes to some extent also
driven by sort of like using data to
figure out these things any idea what
what am what happened in 2010 it was a
really big acceleration mobile I heard
mobile so so actually what's happening
is that the data science is a Facebook
we're forecasting Facebook to be about
700 million users or something like that
and because most of those people using
Facebook on computers they hadn't
intended this massive shift that was
happening in 2010 2011 which is people
getting our smart phones and Facebook
switching the entire team they I even
have large training classes for
engineers just are learning mobile so so
this was the big
change to happen then and then actually
one more thing happen sort of like in
2013-2014 where the Maeda forecast their
Academy kind of not hitting the the
ceiling of growth again but then
something again happened any idea what
happened so 2013-2014 Instagram and
whatsapp could be good answers that's
not what I'm looking for here messenger
is a good answer is not what I'm looking
for so Facebook actually running into
the ceiling of the Internet the number
of people actually the one line so this
started this thing called org which was
intended to get more people in line and
they went to carriers and they gave
basically work with carriers to get
people on line to get free facebook and
this actually were very important for
sort of the continuous growth of
Facebook now what can we learn from this
well we can learn that the initial
forecast of Facebook's growth was about
400 million people but Facebook today is
a 2.1 2.2 billion user platform so it's
a very large platform and the forecasts
were wrong now the forecast wasn't wrong
it just didn't intend and taken account
everything great that the company was
going to do so if there's anything we
can learn from this is that if you're
intentional about growth and you're
really trying to sort of break through
these forecasts in these ceilings you
can grow really really fast so this
applies to every company and I showed
this graph to everyone that you own air
B&B like Aaron leak join the growth you
midden be and try to get them to think
in the same way so natural adoption
which is sort of like that initial
forecast of how fast your part is
growing without any of that work is
always going to eventually slow down but
if you do the things that you do as a
growth team you can't sort of like
continue to push push the growth of your
company now I mentioned this before
having a growth teams before you found
parking market fit isn't really useful
so let's talk about product market fit
is it
so the important term but it's hard to
hard to so exactly define what it is so
the one way that I think about measuring
prime market fit is is these two things
first you find the metric you
can do this for yourself after this
talking find the metric that represents
the value that your customers get from
your product and then you measure the
repeat usage of that metric it sounds
pretty simple and we'll see see if it
works you can make this kind of a table
if you want where you have the company
yeah the metric that represents sort of
the the value you should get from your
product and then you have the ideal
frequency so let's take let's take care
of MB so you get value from a MB when
you are booking and staying so if when
you when you're actually traveling MB
that's when you find that MB is really
valuable it's an amazing amazing
experience unfortunately people don't do
that more than annually so if you would
want to figure out the product market
fit of it air B&B you can always ask
people after the first day but you
wouldn't really know until they booked
again when I come back and book again
so because the booking cycles for travel
is so slow annal will be a good metric
here let's take facebook so facebook if
you come back to facebook being
involuntarily come back to facebook as
an active user you're doing that because
you find value there's something that
makes you come back to Facebook or
Instagram or anything like that and the
question then is how often should I come
back well probably daily or hourly or
something like that they start this they
started looking monthly and then they
went down to daily I think there might
be even going more than that let's talk
about Gus though what's the product
value as a customer of Gus though
whether you get out of using gussto well
when you run your payroll which is sort
of what Gus to do for your employees
that's sort of the one of the best ways
to sort of measure the value you get out
of Gus though I know often you do that
well you run pay low every other week or
every month I'm not gonna go into
details of all of this but for lyft it
might be rides for checker it might be
background checks for striping might be
transactions now for your company you
should figure out what is the one metric
that I can measure easily every day or
every time it happens and what's the
ideal frequency through which that
should happen if you can answer those
two questions you can make a cohort
analysis of your own company right now
and you can start trying to figure out
if you have product market fit so then
you want to measure these things so you
take a graph on one axis you have time
and the other one you have have the
metric that we just decided and from
that you can try to figure out if you
have a product market fit so this
company is measuring this on a weekly
basis the ideal use case of this company
is using this product on a weekly basis
so every week here there's a dot which
is the percent of people that use this
product on week zero the first time they
used it they used it again so let's take
startup school example so I joined
startup school and in week one only 60
percent would come back to school and
then in week four only thirty percent
will come back well that would suggest
the start of school we wouldn't be a
very good product but that would be a
good way to measure if start school is
actually a good product people come back
to all the content they were creating
I'll take another product this is a
great product this is kind of like a
normal product
yeah a normal product would look like
because almost always you have a little
bit too many people in the beginning of
the product and then he will go down
over time but it will sort of flatten
out where you keep measuring these these
events of your metrics this might sound
technical but it's actually just a
representation of how many people each
dawn is how many people does using your
product for that metric that you decided
on that on that time window most good
products flatten out let's look at some
examples here so these are examples that
based on payment retention so this is a
company that you all heard of that
retains 10% after one month and then 12%
after 12 months it's sort of like
unusual who can that be stripe is this
too hard this is Shopify so shop if I
have this product where a lot of people
sign up not that many people continue in
month two but then they kind of stick on
forever so what do we know from from
from from this well if if this curve
would go down to zero or sort of keep
going down then shop at five would be a
bad product
it wouldn't be something that actually
found product market fit and should have
been working in growth in this case they
have good good product market fit and
they should be working on growth they
should do all they can to continue work
on growth they should do something about
sort of like the initial onboarding here
where they lose a lot of people in the
beginning but they should be working on
growth
here's another company 50% retention
after one month and then 10% after 24
months so similar to stripe but like or
similar to Shopify but they continue to
lose users all the way down to even 24
months maybe there's some flattening out
at the very end here but even 12 months
after people start paying for this
product there's they every month fewer
and fewer people pay for the product is
this product market fit hard to say but
but it's not an obvious case that they
have found product market fit so this is
blue apron here's one that's pretty good
so 70 percent retention after 12 months
and then 30 percent after 7 years this
company definitely had product market
fit any ideas of which company this
might be you're all using it Amazon that
hurt Amazon play wasn't the right one
Apple no this is Netflix so 70% of
people that start paying for Netflix pay
for Netflix 7 years down the line that's
definitely a company with market fit
let's just spend every time everything
they can work in growth so raise your
hand if you're if you're measuring your
retention right now not that many people
well there are other ways to figure out
retention if you're really small you
should go out and talk to users you
should ask them questions such as how
would you feel if you can no longer use
my product and you should sort of like
say as close as you can to your users
this is by measuring retention like this
it's very hard when you have 10 users
when you have a thousand it's easier but
when you have 10 users is very this is
not the way to do it you can actually go
and just talk to all any person so there
are other ways to measure it but you
sort of have to know that you have a
product that's retaining otherwise you
shouldn't be working on growth because
you're going to be end up
burning cycles and things it doesn't
matter okay
so a lot of people might be wondering
how does growth and marketing relate to
each other isn't that is it the same
thing or how should I think about it
historically the way you had a company
20 years ago is you had a product team
that made the product and then you had a
marketing team or a product marketing
team the marketed the product that's
nothing's used to work and a lot of the
sort of like hierarchies and companies
or sort of organizations are still based
on this idea that you have a product
team that's separate from the marketing
team and these are different teams and
different skill sets and and that
engineers work over in the product team
and then the marketing people work over
the marketing team actually it's not how
things work anymore so the way you
should think about this is that I'm
gonna come to this in this in a second
is that there is three times three
different types of people that can
organizations that can drive growth
there is what I call the product growth
a growth engineering this has different
names this is effectively product
managers engineers data scientists and
sometimes marketers that work on growth
but they work on growth using technology
so they're actively changing the product
to drive more growth and much of this
work here is about people that already
arrived here product but haven't really
found the value of your product yet and
they're changing the product to make you
grow faster commercial optimizations
fall into this this group some of the
growth channels actually fall into this
group now there's this big other group
here performance marketing which is
effectively Google and Facebook
marketing which is also super technical
and super data-driven I would argue that
these things are very very very similar
so five or ten years ago you would go to
a company you see these being very
different groups maybe different
different floors in the office now they
in my opinion should sit together so
engineers should sit together with
performance marketers and vice versa
because they actually are doing very
similar things now there's this fifth
button fifth thing should be number
before three here
which is brand marketing brand marketing
is sort of like the hardest to measure
the the hardest to measure a type of
marketing where you're not really having
a direct response you're not having
someone directly giving you feedback on
how that marketing perceived you kinda
it can't even measure that very easily
so this is not something that started
should be doing in the early days my
opinion start should not be getting my
brand marketing entail way down the line
when sort of like they hit the limits on
these two things so startups should be
doing these two things and there's some
qualifications to which you can do this
but almost everyone can do this if
you're a startup you have engineers you
can do product growth or growth
engineering or or things like that
all right let's talk about that first
part
Proc growth so your product is a funnel
what does that mean your product has
many many many steps between the first
user and the person sort of like
completing what they're trying to do on
your product let's say I'm on an
ecommerce store and I'm trying to buy
something there are many many steps in
that funnel and what the product growth
team is working on is funnel
optimization or conversion with
optimization so if you look at what we
did at Airbnb on the growth team many of
those growth teams were we're conversion
rate rate optimisation teams they're
working in a specific part of the funnel
so the funnel could start with SEO we
could start with performance marketing
it could start with referrals of
morality but it would jump through a
number of different steps say sign up
would be a very common step or if you're
an e-commerce site payment conversion or
buying conversion all of these steps are
things that as a conversion rate
optimising part of the growth team
should be working on and these are the
some of the easiest things to get
working out and I'm going to be a little
bit high level here because to go into
depth about every single area here is
going to be we can go on for hours so
some of the sort of like good ideas of
areas to start working on for conversion
realizations one of them is translation
so if you have an international product
it's not translated you should be
thinking about that
that immediately drives
and drives more people to sell using a
product the second thing is that
occation so most of your products
probably have some idea of user account
so you can sign up to your product and
you can come back and login to your
product you'd be surprised how much how
hard this is and from Airbnb I know we
spent many years working on just
authentication signing up and logging in
it sounds so simple but it turns out
that's a very fragile moment of users
sort of like flowing through your
product that you can always continue to
make optimizations if you go to a B&B
and you go to Pinterest today assume
that whatever is there in terms of
authentication is the most optimized
version these companies spend enormous
amount of time optimizing sign up
conversion another big area for
commercial optimization is onboarding so
when I come to your product what's the
first thing I experience and sort of
like how do I work what can the product
do to bring me towards the value of the
product is quickly as possible those are
things that you're working when you work
on converting and then another big area
here is purchase conversion sort of like
when I'm about to buy something a
product and actually can take the final
decision
around what you do there's so many
things you can do here alright so then
there is something called growth
channels so what is it growth channels
your chance is sort of how people
discover your product now there is when
you're a small company and I don't know
how how big you guys are but let's say
you have less than 50 users you
shouldn't really be thinking about
growth channels even if you're less than
500 users you probably shouldn't be
thinking about this because it's too
early but the things that you do when
you're small that don't scale have the
word don't scale in it for a reason they
don't actually scale and there are very
few companies who kind of grow big
without growing on one of these scalable
growth channels they're not them any
platforms and the channel slash platform
can be used in the same way they're not
that many things that are really really
big in the world on which you can build
a large company so let's talk about what
those those channels are
so the first thing here is basically you
think through the behavior of your
product and let's talk about the first
one here which is if the way I discover
your product is a rare behavior where
people use Google to find a solution and
this is actually how vary a lot of
products in the world are being
discovered if you have something through
which to answer the question around what
you do once a year you go to Google
probably if you're building a company
trying to answer that question you
should be an easy B in Google so a good
example here might be buying a house you
aren't buying house more than once or
twice in your entire life which means
when you go and buy a house you're
probably going to go to Google which is
not surprisingly there's something like
Zillow or red fin or all of those
different sites that allow you to buy
homes online are entirely optimized for
SEO and and sometimes paid search if you
are using something every day you're not
going to go back to Google every day
you're gonna go straight to that product
you're gonna open the app on your phone
you can go to the straight to the
website whatever it might be you're not
gonna go to Google anymore just kind of
figure out which of the different things
I'm going to use and now their Google is
not the only search and then there are
other search engines sort of like that
you can optimize for us well but Google
is the one that still matters
next behavior do people of my product
already share the product using
word-of-mouth so if that's the case then
there are lots of things you can do
around morality and referrals so you can
grow your product by kind of
accelerating that behavior from your
existing users and you can either
incentivize them with referrals we were
you getting paid or you can do it for
free and with with with using virality
techniques that's having more users on
my product actually improve my
experience so what I mean by that well
if I am building the next LinkedIn it
makes sense the product is not as
valuable when it's just all of us on
LinkedIn but when there's a bunch of
more people and companies on LinkedIn it
makes sense that the value kind of
increases well in that sense you should
absolutely continue to do virality
because every single new user is sort of
opportunity to bring in more users so
there's another way to think about
morality
and then this is that common question I
asked companies in sort of the early
days of YC can you make a list literally
a spreadsheet of all the people in the
world that would use my product let's
say I sell to buyers who decides to
doctors offices they sell to doctors
offices well I can probably make a list
of all the doctors offices in the United
States or in California it wouldn't be
that hard it's totally possible so I
would find a way to make that list and
then would go out and do sales and this
is surprisingly something often
something that you should start with if
you can make the list if you know those
people are you should go on new sales
and the last one here is does my users
have high LTV that's me use a hat that's
does it but do I charge enough for my
product for it to be valuable
well then I should definitely go and do
paid acquisition for example Google and
Facebook I shouldn't do acquisitions or
paid ads unless I actually and charging
for my product all right I'm gonna go
through each one of these sort of like
it's not going to be possible to go into
super deep detail for all of them but
I'm going to go into a little bit deeper
into some of them and not the others all
right let's talk about referrals so I
worked on a referral program at MB for
very long time the way to think about
referrals is sort of an engineered
word-of-mouth so if people are already
talking about your product referrals is
a way through which you can engineer
more people talking about your product
one way could be just making it easier
another way could be by using financial
incentives so in the mb referral program
we had a financial incentive where as a
referre I would make $20 for every users
that would sign up in travel credit and
the servery I would I would get $40 as a
new user of MB in travel credit and we
would we would kind of like start with
that principle and then try to get as
many people what we call through our
first phones as possible so you meant
you notice I'm I use the word
funnel here again so every product is a
funnel and even there a full product
which is a sort of a product of itself
inside the RMB had its own funnel so I'm
not going to go through all of these
details but the way you think about
something that's kind of engineering and
product led is you break it down into
into different steps and then you
measure every single one of these steps
and then you kind of measure the
conversion rate to the very end the
first step here is weekly active users
that saw the referral program so how
many uses saw their full program if I
wasn't measuring this step I wouldn't
know how many people did that when we
started measuring this step and I've
seen this with many other companies when
they who have a referral program is that
a small percentage of your active users
see their full program well how could
you be expected to use it if you can't
see it so we started measuring this in
the early days of a B&B turns out that
there's a lot of opportunity I'm just
telling people about you having your
full program but then there's all these
opportunities to optimize to through
that funnel so there's sort of people
sending invites how many they sent to
the conversion rate to new users into
new guests and finally to them booking
their first-time nights here's another
new display and this slides going to be
available online afterwards you don't
have to I take notes and photos we kind
of separate the funnel into even more
detail and we would continue to optimize
this for years like this all matters a
lot and we would continue to optimize
for years I'm going to go through one
example of sort of like one of those
conversion rate optimization where did
for therefore all program so here's the
referral invite email so if if someone
else if I invited someone one of you
guys you get one of these emails and the
email would say Gustav ahlstrom MIT of
Jerry B&B Gustav sent you 40 dollars on
your first trip on the urban bee you can
book rooms Beauvoir just sign up at 25th
on may 2018 and then there's a button to
call accept the invitation and then
there's a photo of me and my name looks
pretty good now
this email is a result of dozens of
experiments nothing here is random
everything here's for a reason
let's talk about that the first one is
the subject line the subject line has my
name if it's sent to any of my friends
that make them more likely to open it
the sort of like a headline of the email
have a clear value it's very very clear
what this email is about you'd be
surprised how many emails that don't
have a clear headline and the clear
values are what the email most about
these email is about that I sent you $40
on your first trip on this website
called Airbnb this which is sign up by
May 25th 2018 is urgency you should sign
up by May 25th 2018
that's the urgency that makes you
actually go that increases their chance
of people who see this email actually go
and do it the name here except imitation
it's the sense of exclusivity it's not
it doesn't say sign up for reason
because sign up anyone can sign up by
accepting an invitation sends an idea of
exclusivity and finally it has my name
where I live and how long I've been a
user of Airbnb with my photo that's
really strong social proof that I
endorse this website I endorsed this
product so the way you think about this
is sort of how you think about all a
conversion rate optimization it's a set
of optimizations pay growth this is one
of the areas I'm not going to go too
deep too deep into the the options here
the things that matter for pay growth is
that you shouldn't do it unless you have
revenue too many companies are buying
ads when they don't have any revenue or
know how they're gonna make any revenue
that's the big mistake you shouldn't be
doing that if you have revenue there's a
couple concepts that really matter the
first one how much money am i paying for
each new users that arm acquiring it's
called custom acquisition cost or CAC
what's the lifetime value or payback
time of the users that I've acquired
through paid growth so what that means
is what's the longest that I can with
some level of accuracy forecast how much
these users will be worth if a users
paying $10 part
and then we can sort of have this cohort
analysis that we had in beginning with
the attention we can figure out exactly
how much our use is going to be worth
and if my customer acquisition cost is
lower than my lifetime value then that's
good that means you have a great payback
time
if if you only pay $20 for a user that
means if you make $10 per month you have
probably around $20 at two months
payback time that's more complicated in
that but it's sort of like a simplified
version these are the most important
concepts to keep in mind for for pay
growth attribution so this matters if
thinks it complicated if using both
Google and Facebook if you're getting to
some some level of scale you need to
understand what it means to activate a
new paid user to a dollar that you spent
I'm not gonna go too much into detail of
what this means but but this is
something that you should learn if
you're paying time on paper oath and
finally in my opinion there are only
four channels to sort of matters at
scale Facebook Instagram Google and
YouTube these are the very very large
paid growth channels through which many
companies are actually built on these
days sort of like one of the sort
unspoken truth in my opinion is that a
lot of the free channels of growth is
going down and the and the pay channels
are going up a good example of that is
that this hard to grow on the Facebook
newsfeed unless you're paying Facebook
money the same is true for Instagram
it's sort of changing always it when
there's a new platform they often kind
of promote free usage in beginning and
then they start to monetize that and
that sort of was happening for both
Facebook Google and Instagram today all
right search engine optimization so
search engine optimization or SEO some
people might say well this is something
of the past in my experience it is not
it still matters because as long as we
go back to Google to make our decisions
about what we want to do in the future
this matters Google is probably one of
the largest websites in the world it's a
big deal the one thing you should know
about SEO is that there's a difference
between what you see
on a website and what Google see so
Google can't view images Google can't
view JavaScript very easily so if you go
to Airbnb and you see all of this just
remember that Google can't see this so
if you're trying to communicate to
someone who's searching for Stockholm on
it on Google or apartments in Stockholm
this is not what going to be delivered
back to Google Google is going to see a
bunch of lines of text through which
you've marked up in your code and the
Google have hopefully indexed if you
done the right thing and if you haven't
then it's kind of like your fault
so they're a bunch of basics food that
you can do with SEO you just have to get
right the easier thing you can do is to
run your website through an SEO browser
and try to figure out if you only saw
this would you understand what your
practice is about so using clear
language not in JavaScript so you
describe what your product does is the
most basic things you can do for for SEO
there's two different areas of
optimization for SEO and and this is as
high level as it gets so at MMB there's
a team of 20 people working on this of
which 12 or 13 are engineers this is a
really really big deal but but but this
is sort of the high level there's two
types of after my stations for SEO there
are things that you can change on your
website and there are other people in
the world of linking to your web sites
this is the two main levers that you
have an SEO for the on-page optimization
the right way to start is not to start
with like a list make some changes the
right ways to start with the strategy
what am I trying to rank for what
keywords exist on Google today that I
might want to be the number one result
for now to do that you have to do what's
called a keyword analysis or keyword
research you have to try to figure out
what are all the things that people are
searching for that might relate to my
product and then hopefully they have
some amount of large volume that they're
searching for and then I can try to say
well these keywords that have
sort of a medium to high volume and
they're not that much competition around
these keywords those are the ones I want
to rank for when you decide that that
the other areas of impatient of my
stations now are easier because now you
know we're trying to to rank for at
scale but I've seen this as small scale
to SEO at this point is about SEO
experimentation which means you can do
the set of best practices in SEO it
might take you to be a decent size
company but if you want to become a
massive company a really really large
company that's growing through SEO you
have to use experimentation to make
those decisions the other thing that
matter here is off page optimization
who's linking to you so there are lots
of tools you can use to figure out who
were all the websites online the links
to you what's their sort of domain
Authority are they actually
authoritative on the web to have
something there's a huge difference if I
will link to your website and if you
have x link to your website it matters a
lot in sort of how in google's
perception of your of your of your site
so one surprising way there may be is
that we had a lot of press a lot of
people in the world from media would
come and write about Airbnb and that was
surprisingly important for off page
optimization a few people riding my you
either impressed or in other areas
that's actually a great thing if you
don't have anyone writing about you well
you're not gonna have them any links
because the web has changed the aren't
that many links anymore kind of it's not
like everyone have a a website these
days they'll link in to each other so
they said things have changed you have
to be strategic about who are you
getting links from easiest way you can
do is whenever you get written out up by
anyone presser or whatever just ask them
to link to you it matters to you last
thing I'm talking about here is on
growth teams so a growth team today is
typically engineers data scientists
designers product managers and user
researchers these are not the all the
people you might have in your company
today but these are the company
companies that you will have when you
start making decisions to run growth
the way you organize the growth team is
there's sort of two options you either
have the growth team as his own team and
the rest of the practice is the product
team and that's actually sort of my the
the challenge here is that when you when
your small company and and you're not
kind of like somewhat ignorant about
growth what you eat often say is like
I've hired a growth engineer I hired a
growth spike manager that person is
going to be doing all the growth in the
company that's sort of not really a
recipe for success so there's kind of a
fine balance here with between saying
everyone is responsible for growth which
doesn't work and having a small team
that are responsible for all the growth
you kind of have to find a balance here
and the right way to find that balance
it's a set very clear goal and goals and
very clear dividing lines in your
product so a good example here might be
everyone that works on the core product
which is sort of the value of your
product let's say I am gusto the the
running payroll for employees is the
core product now everyone trying to get
to that experience that's sort of like
the growth area of gusto so there'll be
one easy way to kind of make distinction
between growth and product so how do you
decide what to work on you make a simple
calculation of what's the effort what's
the minimal viable thing I want to try
try here and sort of how big of an
outcome can that be so I always try to
forecast out the outcomes before you
actually start doing the work because if
you're forecasting something and a
best-case scenario it's small you
shouldn't be doing it even though it's a
low effort all right I have two small
short sections left of this talk the
first one is called making decisions if
you ask any product manager MB today
what is the most important tool or
learning that you learn to ever be that
you'll apply to your next thing they
would say experiment or experiment
framework or some way of making a B test
inside the company and I'm so happy that
so highl is talking later because I
stole like a quote from his investor
deck
on line this is the quote most of their
world will make decisions by either
guessing or using the gun they will
either be lucky or wrong if you keep
making decisions without using data and
experimentation you will be lucky or
wrong and this is a huge problem so if
you if you kind of get to a scale of a
and B or something even smaller than
that then every decision you're gonna
make that you don't use a/b testing for
you won't actually know what the full
true outcome of that decision might be
so whatever BMB we use experimentation
and a be testing for every single major
decision in an tighten the entire
company so this is how that tool work a
and B but my talks are sort of like more
about how that look like let's say in
your company you decide to ship a
feature and this is how many kind of
measurements of Madaya metric per day
and and the Wednesday here is when a
ship that new feature and then I look at
it two weeks later and looks like that
the metric of that feature went up so
that was a good thing right well it's
not that easy because there's so many
more different factors who knows what
happened between here if you're a soccer
app and the World Cup you started well
that and you wouldn't know if the
features have made a difference if this
was just peak season or whatever you're
doing this is a school app education app
and this is September then you wouldn't
know either so the only way you would
know is what hack what's called a
counterfactual basically an a/b test by
running two different versions of the
same feature the same site the same time
you would be able to know what the true
difference between making these
decisions and not make me it was this
might sound a bit technical but it's
very very important to internalize
because you will get to a point where
you were successful up until that point
and you think that you're so good at
making these decisions and then they get
harder to make and you have to have a
framework to make these decisions so
what we and then because this was so
important MB we built something we call
experiment experiment review experiment
of you is when the whole growth team
would meet in a room like this would go
through all the features that we had
recently built
and before we told you which actually
should have the different features in
the experiment they actually won with
asked the audience so I'm gonna do that
with you guys here so here's a photo our
experiment review we would do this every
two or three weeks it's really fun but
he drove home this one thing which is
that making practices are really hard
alright let's get started so the goal of
this project was to increase the number
of shares from the FMB mobile app
specifically the number of shares of
listings and back at that time we had
two options we had the native share
shoot that you'll know about and then we
have this experiment share sheet which
takes up the entire screen has more
colors the same type of buttons sort of
you can see the difference here now
before I show the answer how many here
think that the native share sheet led to
more shares raise your hand it's behalf
the room how many here thought they'd
the new share sheet that one of our
engineers built drove more ships raise
your hand so the most many hands would
do not race I'm assuming you guys think
there was no difference because this is
so hard you have to make a decision you
have to make a decision you have to have
an opinion if you don't have an opinion
here you're basically saying I can't
decide
so this share sheet led to 40% more
shares so very important in this case
that we'd use experimentation because if
we just gone by a gut we would have been
wrong half of the room more than half of
the room would have been wrong
let's do one more so we send out this
email to existing users of everyone b22
sort of when I would book make a booking
ebon be listen up this email to the
people that I listed as my code
travelers and the email will look in the
control like this where it would have
the itinerary the address to that
listing and the button on that email
would say join Gustav's trip now we
tried a new version where the email look
a little bit different a less content
and then we have a different button here
called accept Gustav's trip imitation
how many here the goal here was to
sign up so people have to click on this
button and then sign up how many here
think that Joan Gustav's trip and the
control led to more signups to raise
your hand some people how many Herot
think that except good stuff stripper
mutation raise your hand that's good
how many here think that there was no
difference so this is a 14% increase of
just changing the basically a name of
the button let's try one more for
simplicity so in this case now they're
sharing experiments I'm kind of giving
you the very easy to understand ones so
the control here was sort of like a
bunch of sharing options on the MMB
listing with had some Twitter icons and
facebook icons demon icons we got
another version of that which the icons
were round and then we have one that was
called sort of square buttons and it was
just displaying email and Facebook and
then you can click on more how many here
thought if the goal was sharing that the
control with the icons one raise your
hand some people how many a thought that
the round buttons were better raise your
hand some people I leave every thought
the square buttons wow you guys are
really good
how many thought there was no difference
well both of these were winners this was
by far the biggest winner and these are
the kind of things that we debated and
because we run experiments you don't
have to debate it anymore so proc
decisions are really hard at scale
you'll want to use experimentation a be
testing to make these decisions because
otherwise it'll be the loudest room it
allows us voice in the room they'll make
the decision so you don't want that to
summary sort of my talk if you're
running startup you should be thinking
about growth before you start working on
current act exceed be measuring your
attention and knowing if people are
using repeatedly using your product you
should pick a metric and then pick a
goal for that metric and drive that
metric towards that goal
very simple and then eventually but not
right away
you should start running a/b tests for
the decisions that are hard to make in
the early days decisions
that hard to make as there might be
obvious but the moment that not easy
anymore you should be building doing
this with experimentation thank you I
think we have time for a couple
questions yes do you have any frameworks
or ways you think about trying to be
honest so the question was around
experimentation in SEO how do you go
about doing that
so what you're trying to test when you
run an on-page experiment what you're
trying to test is sort of the amount of
organic traffic you get from Google and
the sort of how your ranking shifts so
Google actually are changing the
rankings all the time so if you make a
big change on your website on say say
half a say let's call you have an for
every B's case listing pages sorry
searched search results pages so
Stockholm London San Francisco we buy at
one group and then you have New York
Paris and Barcelona B another group you
would change the content on the first
group of pages but not the others within
not too long of a time you would see
more or less traffic going to either of
these groups from Google sometimes
there's no difference but if there is a
difference you'll see more traffic give
you an idea of a very small change you
can make let's change let's let's for
example change the title tag from air
and be listings to the twenty top best
listings in Barcelona one of them is
going to rank better because you can be
more inviting to click on and then you
run that experiment towards the search
engine and then nutrition will kind of
tell you which one is better based on
the amount of traffic and the search or
anything you get yes
[Music]
[Music]
the question was around a B testing how
do I determine if it's right for me when
I'm really early so a B testing is a
function of change so you can have a
medium to small size audience if the
change is large enough it actually can
be since the significant like the
numbers can be significant now what you
can do is you go do you can go to Google
and typing a/b testing calculator and
there's a kind of a form will pop up and
you can type in sort of the the metric
that you have and then they change and
you can see how big the change have to
be for you to be able to see a
difference now if you're really really
small it probably shouldn't shouldn't be
doing maybe testing at all so I would do
a B testing when you have large like
enough traffic that you can see a medium
to small size change within say two or
three weeks so let's say small change
would be a couple of percent if you can
see that in a couple of Ko weeks
kind of like that sort of that level you
could be at that's probably sort of my
general recommendation I've certainly
seen a lot of companies and their early
embracing a/b testing relatively early
and then have that guide saw that their
decision making and I don't think that's
a bad idea because I think that's much
it's better to start a little bit too
early then to start way too late if
those are the only two options
of course you start at the right time
yep how do you apply growth to high
barrier entry market like like health
insurance so I think you should separate
sort of the acceleration of your growth
in that market and the market itself so
if it's hard to reach people that means
you have to probably try to reach to
reach a lot more people before you
actually get sort
if if I hi tell me why we mean by bytes
are like a high barrier yeah yeah so if
you have a risk in regulation involved I
don't think that the principle of growth
changes but if you're purely growing
through sales for example you can apply
a lot of automation and technology to
how to do sales so if I'm a company and
I'm selling to insurance buyers at
startups I might be starting by emailing
10 people and in fact that can email 100
people or a thousand people with the
same type of level of the email itself
is kind of a field as personal and as
direct to that to that receiver as if I
send one email that is remove myself so
there's certainly kind of things you can
apply to your growth that allows you to
reach a lot more people now the growth
doesn't solve any of the risk challenges
at all it doesn't solve any kind of
major market issues and and be certainly
had a lot of issues with legal like
legal challenges in different markets
and sort of growth was disconnected from
that that wasn't sort of our our goal if
you're in a start-up you have those
those problems I don't think you should
solve them solving them and solving
growth are two different things and
they're very separate from each other
and and growth is a way to accelerate
you getting to more health insurance
buyers it doesn't actually say anything
whether that's that's a good thing or a
bad thing yeah
[Music]
do I have any wisdom amusing
non-sustainable tactics a new market
like uber so if you're doing things that
don't scale you sort of have two options
one is they don't scale so you should
stop doing them eventually or you build
sort of a playbook where you take those
skills and you kind of try them in a
different City now they might not
eventually scale so let's say I am out
manually to recruit uber drivers now
that might be an unsustainable growth
tactic it might be working for the first
twenty drivers but eventually it's not
going to have high ROI in comparison to
say running ads on Facebook to recruit
drivers so I think you kind of have to
determine this manual thing that I'm
doing in the very beginning which is
doing things that don't scale which is
sort of recruiting every single user to
become a user of your product eventually
it won't work anymore and you kind of
have to find another channel or you
won't be high ROI in comparison of the
other channels and you'll most companies
will go through this transition period
where you go from say writing content
manually to do engineering changing your
website so that we get more search
traffic for example what about doing
subsidies or incentives for rides well I
don't I actually think the incentives
are super scalable like at MMB we still
have the referral program they're
sending up on hundreds of thousands of
users every day almost which and large
portion of them are sending up through
referrals so that is the example with
subsidies are actually scalable now me
handing you a coupon in your hand it's
not scalable but doing that through an
email system or through whatsapp or
through messenger or some other channel
is actually scalable as long as you're
not losing losing the money so you have
to have a very good ROI calculation on
the money that you're handing out and
knowing that that's incremental money
that if you didn't get get that money
out those users wouldn't actually start
using your product so as long as you
have a good handle on that that is
totally fine yes
[Music]
so question what's around they have two
groups of users so the users and the
paying users and some of them are very
active and some of them are not not
exactly but at least I don't want to pay
how would you use growth there so one of
the things that we're trying to figure
out is what is the retention rate of
those paying users are the actions
taking around and using the product that
they're paying for and what's the
retention rate for the free users do
that change once it starts paying and
then it will look at the conversions or
like how what percent of the freezes and
am I converting to paid and there's many
different ways to do that there's one
which is having the freemium concept you
can also have a free trial which means
you actually don't have freemium you can
just have a very limited set of free
users and then they kind of have to go
to paid but ultimately to the extent
that you should be growing all of this
comes down to how much usage you have
from these the one you they want the
users that your value so if the paid
users are the one you value the most if
if they stop using a product after three
months then you have a more fundamental
problem in the conversion between these
two groups so I would still go back to a
retention and look at usage for those
people and see are they actually
sticking around and using the product
last question from over here yes in the
back
[Music]
[Music]
so the question is sometimes
experimentation can be really hard to
execute is there an ideal sort of
frequency or which which experiment
should I be actually be running for
something like a marketplace
experimentation is really hard that is
correct
so in that case it's easier it's harder
than just setting up a simple tool
online or using Mixpanel to set up your
simple a/b test it's more difficult than
that if you are it's kind of having a
simple product funnel it's generally not
that hard to set up experimentation if
you have an engineer and if you have
decent amount of traffic it's not that
hard to set it up now there's different
kind of products that make
experimentation harder I think that if
you're at this at this stage where you
have a lot of traffic you in my opinion
you don't have really an option you sort
of have to invest in some level of
infrastructure to use data to make
decisions if you don't do that
the alternative cost is you end up
making a lot of bad decision or they're
either long or they're lucky you're
lucky because they're right or you're
wrong so you don't really have an option
but to run experiments and it is true
that there's some type of products
through which experimentation is easy if
you're running a mobile app
experimentation is not that difficult
there are lots of tools you can use to
run experimentations if you're running
out of ideas for experiments well then
you should go back to user research and
you should look at other products that
are sort of look at something like
Pinterest or Airbnb or Facebook they're
probably highly optimized so a lot of
the things in their funnels is there for
very specific reasons because of a/b
testing so I don't have any better
answer then if you don't do it you'll
have a lot of other problems and in
terms of the frequency there is a cost
to setting up an experiment and that
cost should be minimized as much as
possible
but it's sort of like you should just
try to get better at it and and pick the
easiest smallest thing that you can test
and just test that if you have a big new
features you want to test we'll just
test the first part of that feature
don't test all of it and see how people
react to the kind of the first part of
the feature I can talk for hours about
this but thank you very much
[Applause]
you